welcome back to gke Essentials my name
is Anthony Bouchon
we've already covered what you should
consider if you're a central platform
team looking to build a large-scale gke
cluster today we'll talk about what you
might consider if you're a central
platform team who wants individual
service owners to move fast with their
own smaller scale gke clusters let's get
right to it
[Music]
there are probably a dozen jokes out
there about standards in our industry
namely about how many there are but I
promise you in this scenario they're
really important
you see even if you don't own each gke
cluster individually you want to make
sure that users start with a cluster
setup that you as a central team can
recommend
if we don't well we could end up with
local Optimum traps or even worse
clusters that are not up to par with the
standards of your organization
you can think of defining these
standards across two dimensions
one configuration specific to gke
clusters
this means the setup of the underlying
Cloud infrastructure and gke features
that the cluster might enable
and two kubernetes resources you want in
every cluster these could be Network
policies cluster roles or other
resources provisioned using the
kubernetes API both are important if we
want to give teams power to move
independently and safely so let's
introduce a few ways in which GK users
can achieve this today starting with gke
cluster configuration now we can't
discuss standardizing Cloud resources
without talking about terraform one of
the most popular open source tools that
lets you write Common configuration
across infrastructure providers
and while you could use terraform to
provision individual Resources with
every configurable option imaginable
terraform also provides users the
ability to create modules
modules are a great way to group
resources in gke's example you might
group a cluster resource a few node pool
resources and a service account resource
modules are also a way to provide
opinionated infrastructure using
terraform's ability to provide fixed
values to implement your organization's
best practices like for example you
could ensure that GK clusters have
Network policy enabled while authoring
your own modules can help you codify
your organization's best practices for
security or performance you can also
find modules provided by Google for your
use or reference in the description
below alternatively if you are deeply
invested in tooling from the kubernetes
ecosystem you can also evaluate defining
your gke clusters using something called
config connector
using kubernetes custom resources and
controllers built by Google you can use
config connector to write your Cloud
infrastructure including your gke
clusters using the kubernetes API this
allows you to use tooling by customize
and kept to templateize and package your
manifest defining your infrastructure in
the same way you might for workload
definitions in kubernetes finally
whereas you may run the terraform CLI
packaged in steps of a pipeline or some
automation tool config connector is run
via kubernetes controller this means
that they are constantly driving
resource current state to your desired
state
this adds in an element of diff
reconciliation which can help prevent
drift or unwanted changes made manually
to your set of gke clusters
and if you want those controllers for
config connector managed for you by
Google you can check out a service
called config controller alright so if
we use either of the aforementioned
tools right we should have our GK
clusters provision
now what now we might want to provision
common kubernetes resources to these
clusters that teams create
Google's config sync helps you achieve
this via pattern called git Ops in short
meaning that we are using git as a
source of truth from which multiple
clusters can pull kubernetes manifests
with config sync each cluster will have
a local component that pulls manifests
from a git repository and applies them
as kubernetes resources to their
respective cluster
like config connector config sync
performs diff reconciliation but for
these kubernetes resources that belong
in each gke cluster
this means that each cluster side
component of config sync is constantly
ensuring that resources in the git repo
match what exists in the cluster so if
you want consistent cluster roles
storage classes demon sets or network
policies you can use config sync to make
sure they'll always be present in your
gke clusters now there's a lot in this
space but hopefully this gives you the
lay of the land and a place to start
there are a few next steps if you're
just getting started on this journey
that I might recommend for example you
can evaluate how you can enforce the
cluster configurations and kubernetes
resources adhere to policies that you
define using projects like open policy
agent
you can also examine if you could
benefit from more granular control with
config sync by having subsets of
clusters pull subsets of resources that
match their clusters profile but perhaps
most important is to now look at these
tools and principles in the context of
your team your people and your
organization
so that it makes sense with what works
for y'all check out the links in the
description below to learn more and as
always thank you for your time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]